i forget what we were doing as far as
the game goes we finished off by
accidentally stumbling upon the ending
of the story but we still haven't done
all the crafting and no we should like
build a base
yeah build a base and then these ants
uh seem to be awfully friendly that's
that's nice that's really nice
oh they're cute i've uh been told that
maybe building a base on top of like
the baseball or somewhere not on the
ground
is better on top of the baseball yeah do
you remember how we woke up to the wolf
spider
ripping down our walls no i don't
remember that i recall
apparently that's less likely to happen
on an elevated position
well i mean or we could just kill it you
know guys i have a thirst
uh yeah water's tough you can make like
containers for water
yeah we can make a canteen and we can
make a dew catcher we should definitely
make a dew catcher make a dew catcher if
we know anything from raft it's that
catch and dew is good
we got spider webs right from the wolf
spider
i don't remember looting it i just
remember killing it i have
spider venom spider fang spider chunk
which looks like a ball sack
the ant it's attacking our wall why are
you doing this my friend
hey that's our wall hey stop it
oh it's attacking a bug back here oh
that's fine oh [ __ ]
i'm just gonna take that meat you just
got and casually cook that for myself
they're helping us
if we make them our friends they'll help
us oh god i'm thirsty
where do we find grubs i'm pretty sure
the dirt things moving around are grubs
oh
shuffle oh so we need shovels yeah
shovel acorn shovel
i can make it actually right now all
right uh i guess i just look on the
ground for them
yeah i think they're little like dirt
things on the ground what do we need
grubs for
to make water canteens so that we can
actually like oh okay
store some of it chest we need to make
like a storage chest right
yeah that would be that would be killer
oh the ants like our cooked food okay we
need to not leave the food on the fire
oh did you guys
oh my god there's a horde of ants over
here that just killed a weevil
apparently they really don't like
weevils man okay we have a storage
chest in our little [ __ ] house that's
awesome man
oh my god guys i'm attracting the ants
apparently
the food god has been removed oh they're
hunting the weevil
okay okay we're good we're good we're
good okay i worry that if we anger the
ants all of the ants will be against us
permanently
is anyone buy the thing no what's the i
have a horde of ants with me and i
i needed oh wait there is a white nest
are you now god of the ants mark there
are 500 ants trying to get into the back
of our basement hang on let me take a
look
it's because i'm cooking the things on
the floor they want to eat the weevil
roast
oh my god
dude i am one with the ants dude you're
about to be
one with the ants oh man they what
they're after well oh they're angry oh
god oh they're up to me oh god what'd
you do
i don't know the can why are we safe up
here
i can't tell i think we're saying what
are they doing they're doing something
to the grass
what is happening my god they're
attacking our base
guys i think the ants are not our
friends what happened
i don't know i think i accidentally
stabbed one but they
lost their [ __ ] no they're fighting one
of them's got a piece of meat and
they're all trying to get it
okay they're leaving they took something
and they're out yeah no they're the [ __ ]
out now they're coming back here never
mind oh god i spoke to you we need to
build a base in the sky
this oh spider watch out spider oh
[ __ ] no i see it it's big don't come
this way
let's go on the baseball let's go up on
top of the baseball baseball up on the
baseball
okay any water water there's no water
all right yeah water is a problem yeah
no i've been out of water for ages
there's a there's a
there's a puddle of piss that we could
drink from but it's not good
water we're right by a big old puddle of
juice
water larvae anything
something may just have to go for the
piss water then like
find food so drink the piss wasser [ __ ]
all our food out
stuff food back in it's a vicious cycle
man it'll oh
ants are we cool yet or what what are we
are we cool
there we go there's there's demonic over
here jesus christ
oh what is this oh i saved you you're so
happy
now die oh we've got a quest
oh i found a hole in the ground well
this looks good all right
i'm beginning the process of building
stuff on top of the baseball
okay i'm gonna put a workbench up there
and then i'm gonna put our beds up there
okay that sounds great i didn't mean
that to sound sarcastic that's
legitimate
oh good good great for you
mark there's water on me two waters two
waters all right go for it
i'm good i i did the i did the piss
wasser strat earlier so
i'm only 20 thirsty apparently do you
want the watermark i don't need it
anymore i
just i let's leave it i guess i don't
know man
consume i just ate a bug
you consumed the bug i'm dead apparently
what the hell all right i'm coming don't
eat the bugs
they are bad did you consume raw meat
yeah is that bad
well i don't know yeah we're supposed to
cook it i've been cooking
no i never cooked a thing in my life
there's no way you're going to find me
i'm giving up i'm giving up i'm giving
up i'm giving up
i'm giving mark look out oh thanks man
hey at least i spawned with water that's
how we're going to solve this
we just die and then get our water
die near camp get your crap back yeah
that's all we need have we been in the
cookie box
the cookie box i don't remember seeing a
cookie box there's a lot of this map but
we have not expected we need level two
tools to get in here
i don't even know how we get level two
tools yeah level two either
all right well uh we should there's like
a storage shed way off in the distance
uh there's like the the the dry area
with
dust kicking up there's the house area
there's a lot of area in this map that
we haven't
touched okay let's try this uh take oh
thank you and slime old torch
okay thank you
okay ooh this is the big ant area this
is the not front oh but that's not
fun and bad ants the bad ants
are you having some kind of trouble with
the ants yeah the ants kind of suck
uh don't go oh they're still there oh hi
hey uh the the army ants or whatever
they are
there was like a couple ants here and
there why are there all of a sudden
hundreds i don't know man i think it's
just the cooked food is
starting to draw him in whoa what are
you
who put the storage container down here
why i'm seeing i did that before
oh before we talk about moving on no no
no no no no ah it squirted at me
ew i'm gross that's gonna be taken out
of context later
it's like everything i say could be
taken out of context that's
that's gonna be taken out of context
later yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's gonna be
taken out of context later oh come on
guys lay off
that's that's probably not going to be
taken out right contacts later nailed it
i got it i'm so
gosh darn good hey we got research or
something
yeah because i killed the last day
wow
dude i'm in spider hell there's a lake i
found a lake
if this is fresh water here and not an
ocean which why would it be an ocean
we're in the backyard
uh yeah this is unlimited water over
here so there is there is a lake and
it's
oh no it's poop water it's poop water
oh [ __ ] i heard the whoa
there's also an ant down here that's
glowy-eyed in the water uh it's not
happy
all right whatever okay grass moving
means
death yeah that grass moving is no good
dude there's stuff at the bottom of the
lake the lake calls to me
i don't know if i fall in i don't think
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god odd night is falling and i'm on
the wrong side of the island
island i don't know is this an island
probably
just i'm by the tree why are you by the
tree
i say as i'm on the other side of the
lake oh there's really no end to this i
thought that this would loop around
uh guys i uh might be alone tonight
are you in some kind of trouble no not
trouble necessarily
but i am literally only getting farther
away from you guys as i try to loop
around
but the loop around just drives me
farther and farther away
there stopped being grass there's no
resources to pick up anymore
i think this is in the unfinished area
have you
left the map no not yet but it seems
like i thought this would loop around
and it really doesn't
it super doesn't it super doesn't i
might i'm gonna have to go in the lake
oh my god mark you were so far i know
look
i thought i was gonna get oh god
oh can you tell how far away he is i'm
at the edge of the tree and i can see
where he is hi from here i gotta go in
the river
oh my god there's something at the
bottom
oh please tell me there's no like fish
in here
i can't no i can't break the surface
tension of the water
hey um friends yes what's up hey
should i just give up yes it is it is
shockingly difficult to
jump out of the water there we go i'm up
i'm on the other side okay well that
that was awful oh
no no no no no
you all right no oh i'm worried
oh no oh no i got a death bug guys
a death bug my backpack is so far away
in a random direction oh no did it fall
like through the map or something
i don't know it's five it's 400 500
centimeters away in a place i wasn't
oh cola from the
there's a few drops i'm in a can and
it's pretty grand
i spit lines max spit lines
oh hey mark it up
nailed it okay can i actually get up
here no there's no point you save a drop
in here oh you did
yeah i did totally for you thank you why
is my backpack
in the ocean lake what fresh hell is
this
yeah that ocean lake kind of sucks my
journey to find
a single larva has ended in failure i'm
coming back home
my backpack is just floating in the
water why
oh no be careful going out there it's
hard to get out of the lake
once you're in it it was not hard at all
to get out of the lake
losers oh my god is the tree curse
bloating for anyone else or is that just
for me
what there's plenty of the purple
corsplosions
coming out of the trees oh yeah yeah
that's normal
oh yeah that's where we found the ending
right yeah apparently we can find
things to put into that robot there and
we can buy recipes from it for more
crafting stuff that we don't have
and like the tape recorder things yeah i
think i think that's oh i found one of
those oh we should go talk to the robot
then
we have to find that purple science
blobs as currency but i think the tape
recorders would unlock the recipes to
buy oh
yeah you need a level two hammer to get
this mint how do you get a little yeah
i don't know how to upgrade stuff how do
you upgrade stuff
i somehow made it back to our base i
thought i was in a completely different
area i'm gonna analyze this
spider's ball sack was analyzing
analyzing
purple two testicles interesting
interesting oh spider hood
i guess i'll grab this so this is going
to detect more science nearby so we'll
look at that
insect bow do you want to save up for
fortified bases or should i go ahead and
grab
torch upgrade and multi-story bases oh
multi-story basis sounds cool
i am already working on a multi-story
base so i would appreciate that for sure
sure and i'll grab the torch upgrade too
then just the soda can you were in mark
yeah yeah there might be another drop in
there if wade left you it i don't know
if he did
uh there was only one drop but it might
have replenished
nope i'm just gonna go home i don't like
being in spider land
we can do quests for this guy to get
more science
okay well that's cool oh i can accept
all of these yeah just get them yeah
because we'll okay
four soldier ants and three weevils oh
my god i know where the soldier ants are
oh guys i put a marker on our base so
now there's a flag at our base oh there
is that's handy i
i just built that so i think that's why
they just uh i finished i finished the
building of it
thank you you're welcome team
um well all right i'm climbing i'm
climbing at rake
it's very seems good it's very foggy
this is terrifying
oh my god it's a thick fog it is
thick i bought an upgrade that's
supposed to show near science or
in science nearby i don't know how it
works exactly
is it nearby this dude or nearby us uh i
have no idea
let me let me talk to him again i'll see
if i can find him why why why why
no bad ant about dying to ant yeah the
is is it the big one
the big answer it's over by the platform
oh he's big yeah he's big
yeah he's big oh there's i'm on a big
rock and there's a
weird there's some kind of a bug stuck
in the
[Music]
i touched science i got science an
upgrade for the scab
scanner module that allows it to detect
nearby raw science how do we use your
scanner
module i don't know man
i think so if you look in the bottom
left sometimes when you're near
a um what is it called when you're near
one of the research stations
the bottom left thing will be at you
it's like
telling you you're close to that so that
must do that
yeah okay so i found raw science it's
just like a purple
grape looking thing and it starts like
little yellow gets more and more pulls i
got close to it
they're fine you know we could sleep uh
what if we weren't idiots
what is that oh what is that
oh god okay i don't know oh my god i'm
oh my god i'm gonna die
i think mark's in trouble don't come
here where i am
i super wasn't i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die this is it i'm gonna
uh so i'm gonna come like revive you or
something no no no
there are fungus infected weevils
from your knees
yeah the base is now a white marker with
a house symbol
i love that i love that i love that
dude this game is terrifying why are the
weeds too thick i want a weed
i need some weed oh it's just being in
here
there's like a gas in the air yeah don't
come to this area
mark i'm on my way what are you doing
what are these tiny things
oh these are mites oh this is an
infected mite
infected light yeah infected mite that's
what it said
so far so good please don't fall okay
oh i oh i don't have a shovel i see
where there's a grub here
oh man i've been looking for that
forever can i make a shovel on me do i
have to be a thing
i think it's a workbench thing where are
you that you're finding that
um i'm buy a juice box near the tree
okay so it must be like by the tree or
something because i haven't seen
anything out here there's seemingly no
way to make a stare of any sort which
seems crazy
that does seem crazy or a floor of any
sort that does seem crazy
i'm going to try to kill a soldier ant
in in the next list of mark's dumb ideas
uh i'm going to try to kill a soldier
remember when
we could sleep you want to sleep oh
he's bad i wouldn't oh he's mad he's mad
oh he's mad is he upsetting you
this is a large surprise to me i give up
i give up
i give up i give up mark i can't believe
he got mad
we might need to uh work together to
take them out yeah maybe i'm gonna come
home uh let's sleep
i think it's a good idea if we sleep i
agree funny cool
good also when we sleep when we wake up
our food and thirst are gonna be like
bad again so don't bother eating or
drinking before sleeping
oh that's dumb oh this is
what are lovely so bob how are you
flying you're flying
so make sure you set your spawn here too
you just did yeah spawn point
anyone else tired i guess it wouldn't be
the worst in the world if we didn't
anyone else then uh we'd just respawn
right underneath the baseball look it's
fine look
wait why you got a poo poo on on bob's
things that he carefully made for us
i spent a lot of time on this he spent a
lot of time
i don't think i poo-pooed at all chad
says we got to get floors from the robot
guy i don't like that i i bought all
that stuff the only thing i couldn't do
was fortified bases
floors must be how you fortify i guess
so yeah you got to fortify it man
it seems pretty high a thousand science
for that where the hell are we gonna
find five thousand science
yeah just find it man god do we have to
spell it out for you
okay i guess i guess it'll be set to
find it how do you differentiate the
soldier ants from the other ones are
they just bigger
you want to come fight them come on come
with me i need to find food and water to
start the day off though
yeah good luck with the water i've been
trying haven't found a single
i passed a whole bunch of water on the
way back from the tree the tree
seemingly has lots of water around it
that's impossible there's no such thing
as water i'm gonna go
back toward the tree to find water and
then i'll come back and help you with
the ants
there's no such thing as water oh mark
there's an ant there's one of your ants
here at the
thing no there's two of them we're going
to kill them together man
oh i do have floors i'm just an idiot
guys don't worry we have floors
i'm just an imbecile are you dumb bob i
am dumb
wait let's do this it's called a floor
okay oh my god
oh god you hurt so bad
wait you're helping me you're helping me
right you're on the way you guys need
some sort of assistance
oh that's not what you want go bob
that's not what you want
got one it's dead okay yeah
friend he had a friend oh that was gross
i hear him skidding oh it's oh yeah he's
actually below us okay i'm going in
come here you yeah fights on oh you're
you're in
you guys you guys need help or are you
good we're good wow
watch out he's got pincers
all right guys i'm starting on our base
and it's definitely
i'm definitely doing it the right way
and look i found water literally 10 feet
away from where i was just hanging out
no water guys
i don't know how to break this to your
juice box is going to give me found the
box delivered i just drew it all over
myself thank you
i spat everywhere mark there's water on
me yes i've got p
i found p guys i there's no water
there's only plate on me
there's only p oh uh the grubs mark do
you want me to find grubs yeah where are
they
if you guys see any weed stems we really
need a lot of weed stems
uh what gives you weed stems you cut
down the dandelions or weeds but you
need better acts
for weeds we need to upgrade our tools
yeah that's why we're doing the quests
come on man keep up
does that give us tools it helps the guy
who's going to give us tools come on man
keep up
unless fortify fortified bases is tools
come on man keep up you're going at a
speed higher than my
processing capabilities i know come on
man keep up
also my science detector is going off
here
okay nerd there's a nerd over here come
on no
science detector's going off come on
no come on yeah i see dirt okay i'm
coming
oh how how how does this work
oh oh my god oh that's big get it what
in the [ __ ]
hell i get it it's dead man you're
cursing a lot man don't you know
you can't do that no what did i say did
i say bad things you said
such bad things i meant to say ding dong
dingleberry dang it
somehow i think that's worse i see
another grub all right go get it you're
you're apparently grub man now
how what do we need from the grubs hide
goop
just grub hide i don't know you you need
to turn them into canteens
no we need to insert them we need to
convert them into water bottles
look i don't know how to tell you this
is what you do you turn them into water
bottles
and then we make a big acorn jug in the
center of our thing
so that we can make more of them [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay so part of my language
so each grub gives one hide it takes
three hide
to get one canteen i just got a third
grub so i've got enough for one canteen
all right cool man all right guys i'm
making the worst staircase ever so we
can get up either side of our base
it's absolutely been worth my time don't
ask me i have no questions
good i have one question don't what how
are you so amazing
good wouldn't you like to know please
don't look at me don't look at me
guys you're gonna be i think you're
gonna be really impressed with the bass
when you get here
is it gonna be nuts it's nutty
it's not even just nuts it's not not
horrific
how how are you so amazing it's nuts
i don't like that one it's not that how
do you do it you know
skill yes you got to be real careful
when you're up on the base i do need to
warn you
uh it's only sort of constructed so if
we
if we roll off tonight are we just going
to fall off and die
listen i just i eated my hammer into the
next
century oh i found i found a different
research base
weird i can analyze the ants ball sack
as well
you're analyzing so many nuts these days
yeah we need some sac
i found out champion found out how to
make rubber out of that
sack who's the spider oh it's a spider
oh what i'm stuck in goo he webbed me
oh hey maybe that's how you get spider
silk i can't go don't worry it's all
right
ah i cut myself out i did not get spider
silk ah well that's
whoa this spider is very happy to kill
the spider to get it
you you want me to kill this spider by
myself is that what you want i'm pretty
sure
you should kill it what i'm saying is
mark kill it
you're the most talented fighter among
us okay i will
for you okay we'll do it then i'm doing
it i'm
it's an orb weaver i don't know what
that means oh they make cool
orb nests yeah they apparently do lots
of
very silky asses ow oh that hurts so bad
ah i'm dead
sorry i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing near you right okay fair enough
yeah i love wade i love you
thank you love you sue wade your advice
was very poor
it ended with me guys
um i think my spear hit you and not the
spider
i think instead of helping you i
finished you off
oh well that's not so good so that's my
bad
all right uh i guess i'll hey what's up
dude hey what's up hey let me look at
this base let me
look at the actually what the hell
dude we're gonna have such an enormous
sky castle you have no idea
castle in the sky i you thought i was
[ __ ] on you well that's not the word
you thought i
no way not my pants
anyway well all you got to do is run
interference on that spider
and then i'll swoop in grab my stuff and
i'll yeah i'm working on
luring it away oh yeah you work on that
don't worry work on it i gotta slurp a
piss
there's so much good water around this
tree there's
plenty of piss piss-men i don't know why
you're always hating on the man's piss
slurping
yeah thank you let him slurp i'm getting
it
i just don't understand away that's what
i say dude i don't mean to
just piss water look i bet you got your
water and i bet it's fine
but look i i've got a there's an
infinite supply this is a spider web
i'm all itchy i hate looking at spiders
man it [ __ ] me up
i am punching a spider web i have spider
silk i'm getting spider silk i'm getting
so much spider soap
really so punching the web gets better
there's a different web i am punching
the crap out of it i am getting so much
spider silk i feel
well [ __ ] i am punching this web sponge
are we morons no there's a diff it's a
more different
looking one oh god oh hey did you run
interference
good thank you i'm free i'm out thank
you
okay good i lost my spear but honestly
it's okay you're
is you have a hammer over here an axe
over here i got everything you have a
hammer
this there's a random hammer on there oh
yeah that's the hammer that i somehow
eated off the mountain
i don't know how that happened but it
did it went away
i was going for an acorn swing and my
strength was just too immense like my
my huge muscles just yucked it uh way
too far away
um how much silk did you get from that
uh 14
that's enough for a dew collector we
probably need more than one duke
collector since there's three of us but
like that's enough for at least the
first one maybe two
that's fine i don't know how much money
it's fair i'm bringing it back bob i'm
bringing back the supplies
for you for us for weeks
for our family i literally like either
i'm an idiot and i've seen so many and i
haven't
found them or there's no grub is this
more pee
no it's incredible it's incredible this
p it's incredible
it was the brightest yellowest liquid
and it
did so much good for my body i want that
as my ringtone
is this p it's incredible it's
incredible
make that your bit donation noise
this is p it's incredible there's
another one
there it is again oh my god multiple
usable takes
yeah all right hey i've got the supplies
uh there's some
more ball sacks there they're different
ball sacks by the way they're
oh different ball [ __ ]
there's murder ants oh no we're good
we're good it's fine
look at all these douchebags i don't
know what was just floating in front of
my eyes
i don't like it there's something
floating here
it's a nap nat is dead
didn't it wait what oh what
oh i went into third person mode how did
what what
what what what what what
i don't know what that's a thing i went
into
i'm in third person mode now wait did
you hit control u
i no no way what you
oh it's you it's you oh it is just you
control you
gives you like an out of body experience
yeah i think it's controlling third
person mode it's do you listen
well no no no no no it's not that
control
just you this third person i think it's
gonna kill you controlling you doesn't
do anything else that's not it
pat what's the button that pat showed me
chat what was the thing pat told me
that makes you go weird i can't take
these testicles out of the chest
the testicles remain in the chesticles
alt you
all you will [ __ ] your day what where am
i
where was i all right back to the all
right
i'm holding up now i'm full of pee
and i need some food insect bow
i just made that i'm pretty sure that's
like the one of the best weapons you can
make
yeah i remember hearing somebody i made
it now i know it's very good
i know but i made it like if i had to
explain it anymore i would just say it
does a lot of damage and is very useful
i know i have it currently in my
possession
if you had one you'd be virtually
unstoppable i
am because i got one do i have to go
into those scary tunnels to find more
grubs
is that maybe you should definitely do
that go into the soldier ant tunnel
say hi to him you know where it is oh
yeah i forgot we made love there uh
never mind what do you guys do while i'm
not around that was someone else
not that i want to say we have a ladybug
that's kind of stuck over here
i would be really curious to try and
kill it but i'm really terrified it
would be
not as stuck as i think it would be
quite tough i think when you hit things
they typically like
bounce backwards and do get unstuck well
that's not what you want
wait till i get my bow ready
okay did i oh my
god i have arrows inside me hey mark
don't look at me
my did you dude
you get those arrows buddy yeah there's
an arrow right below me yeah i'm
good wade welcome to the base oh guys i
made danger beds accidentally
dude i love a dangerous sleep oh my god
who gets this one out of here hang on i
need a little bit more anyone got clover
chunks cause i think it's that long
put some in the chest i think thanks
buddy you're welcome
don't let me set that as my spawn point
so i really
gotta be real careful on these spawn
points okay i really hope
that you spawn in that thing and fall
and die if you respond
so i have a bow and a hundred arrows
i am so holy [ __ ] i'm ready though
are you ready to [ __ ] yeah
i'm ready to bro
what time for me to test out this book
hey i'm gonna let's go let's go kill
this oh
my bow's broken my bros my bro my boat
guys
are you looking at my bow guys my bro
my bro wait do you see something wrong
with my bow
no is your bro okay bro my bro
i'm gonna shoot my bro this ladybug it's
supposed to look i'm pretty sure
all right okay sure shooting
i shot didn't do nearly as much damage
it it stuck
oh it's stuck yeah i know that's why
this is the one i was saying it stuck
you could just shoot it and get your
arrows back
i'll stab it
well this is just sad now these things
are tough as hell though so
this ant is watching us just like ha
take that you [ __ ]
it does really weird stuff on my screen
when you throw your
spear yeah oh
okay made a mess i don't see anything to
pick up did you guys get something
nope all right i think it shot into the
under verse
i'm pretty sure well at least we know in
a fair fight
we can win yeah yeah that was easy
i full oh i shouldn't have eaten we're
about to sleep i'm an idiot don't eat
don't drink don't even think about life
idiot
hang on i'm moving i'm moving i'm moving
on oh god to the east side hang on
things are really
jiggly in this game can i make a danger
work bench
that's the real question oh boy do i
have how dangerous can this workbench be
what you really want to do is you put
put some floors down and the game is
like
oh yeah yeah you put a workbench out
here and then you just take the
workbench
and you just boop that right over there
and it turns
out these floors don't have to exist
anymore that's great i love that
that's good look how much space we're
saving on the on this
on the scaffolding it really is
incredible i mean physics just work
differently when you're at a smaller
scale yeah gravity doesn't affect us the
same because of how tiny we are
exactly that's what i've always been
saying well shoot shall we sleep
can we do this yeah i'm ready for
whatever this is going to lead
to baby oh come on guys hop in
why does it say two of four ready to
sleep what
who is here who's here oh wait what
are we being haunted someone randomly
joined oh
there's no there's no fourth player on
the player list
i kicked them okay oh okay how do you
disable notifications for people that
are spamming [ __ ] friend requests
i don't know i did that i guess already
all right we didn't die
thankfully um somehow oh the workbench
is very usable
i would describe that as very usable
it's time for me to go
hunting i'm gonna complete this quest oh
i love this
back door yeah i made it back i made a
back entrance
that's awesome that's so cool i'm gonna
go kill me some ants
if you hear screaming in the next few
minutes you know that i succeeded
there's a regular amp down here but i
need to kill the
big ants
oh they charge far
ow what the hell oh
we're halfway there got one
that's not how that's worth thank you oh
living on a prayer oh please don't come
up here
we're safer oh god okay if you kill a
soldier and the other ants the small
ones get mad
friends what
look i don't want to do this little guy
it can hurt me
it's just a little worker the whole
structure goes away if you do this
oh what did you no no no no
no i agree no no
what did you what what happened no no
no oh no no
no oh it's still there what'd you do no
it's your ass back
everything's fine don't worry about it
get your ass back here you have my spear
you [ __ ]
whatever's happening with weight is not
fine i'm going to help wade then
it's throwing grass at me that doesn't
seem like a thing that it would my
spear is somewhere between you and me
and this oh
oh yeah you got me you got your magic
yeah magic what
i forgot about what oh my god oh my god
mark come up here oh my god oh my god oh
my god am i is it safe
it's safe if you don't stand right at
the edge oh
i don't think i can get in here the
holes are too small
it has so much health okay i need a [ __ ]
ton of weed stems and clover leaves
let's do this
jesus oh my spear is stuck in its head
ow ow ow oh my spear
i got my spear hey nice oh god
it's halfway dead shoot dang it
almost we got it up here it's up there
oh come here you [ __ ] so twitchy i
will hammer yes
nice wait grab it sack
oh i've got some arrows for you oh
thanks thank you good thing these come
back i didn't need to make a hundred you
know your spears down there
there's a there's a whole bunch more out
there in the grass oh boy
we killed orb weaver we did it we did it
we're gods
well yeah you know what i'll let you
have that one victory slurp
refreshing all right i need water so i'm
going to the tree
no wait no dude dude my dude come here
let me show you
oh man you're really sweet we killed
norb weaver all through your victory
look here tp slurp it's this wait come
on oh god not this slurpee's anything
this slurp it up yeah
i'm gonna just find some non-piss god
that was
that was great man i'm glad we did that
together what did i just actually eat
i don't know man anyway it's the
memories we
share i really make friendship special
you drink urine together then you're
in together
did you drink some more i heard feeling
refreshed
oh that must have been someone else bob
what do we need to get for you
i really need water that's the thing i
need i know
i know that's not easier done than said
or there's so much pee
but i don't everywhere it doesn't sound
good too
it's all over the place it's not a good
that's
bad for three also there is also
dying all right it looks like i'm
drinking pee boys the tree is covered in
water
all right i know no one ever wants to
come to the tree but like there's so
much water here
oh why there's no god
hey guys i made a ghost scaffolding is
that impressive
yes i'm learning about construction and
how [ __ ] doesn't need to exist
for it to exist wow that is beautiful
it really doesn't need to exist for you
to build it
that's fascinating yeah so we got a we
got a nice
nice tall base there and for like half
the resources
yeah that's pretty cool man that's
pretty cool it's something
i take full credit for that you want to
see the way down bro
yeah i do yeah i do check this [ __ ] out
yay whoa let me try that
girl um i got an auto saving as that
whatever happened just happened
all right cool it didn't work for me no
you gotta you gotta really believe
okay i gotta believe like try it again
and believe this time
[Music]
you